OPEN JOBS THAN THERE ARE
UNEMPLOYED AMERICANS.
WE ARE JUST HOURS AWAY FROM A
SCHEDULED VOTE IN THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON WHETHER
TO HOLD ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR IN CONTEMPT OVER HIS
REFUSAL TO RELEASE AN UNREDACTED
ADDITION OF THE MUELLER REPORT
AND OTHER EVIDENCE INCLUDING
GRAND JURY MATERIAL.
THERE SEEMS TO BE AT LEAST A
RHETORICAL SPLIT BETWEEN BARR
AND HIS FBI DIRECTOR, WHETHER
THE GOVERNMENT SPIED ON THE
TRUMP PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE SHOWS US
TONIGHT.
>> THINK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE
HERE.
>> DURING A ROUTINE BUDGET
HEARING, A SENATE DEMOCRAT ASKED
A WIDE-RANGING QUESTION ABOUT
FBI TACTICS WITH THE DIRECTOR
USING THE SPYING LANGUAGE AS HIS
BOSS, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> THAT IS NOT THE TERM THAT I
WOULD USE.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT IT IS A
"NO."
>> I BELIEVE FBI IS INVOLVED IN
AN INVESTIGATIVE ACTIVITY THAT
INCLUDE SURVEILLANCE ACTIVITY.
>> LAST MONTH BARR SAID THAT
SPYING WAS ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
LEADING TO POLITICAL PUSHBACK IN
THE MEDIA FRENZY.
LAST WEEK BARR STOOD BY HIS
CHOICE OF LANGUAGE.
>> I THINK THAT SPYING IS A GOOD
ENGLISH WORD THAT DOES NOT HAVE
SYNONYMS, BECAUSE IT IS THE
BROADEST WORD AND INCORPORATING
ALL FORMS OF COVERT INTELLIGENCE
COLLECTIONS.
>> DURING THE 2016 CAMPAIGN, THE
FBI SECURITY SURVEILLANCE WERE
IMPORTED TRUMP CAMPAIGN AID
CARTER PAGE THAT ALLOWS FOR
COMMUNICATIONS COLLECTION WELL
BEYOND THE ORIGINAL TARGET.
WHEN PRESS DIRECTOR RAY ANSWERED
CAREFULLY SAYING THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL INVESTIGATION
INTO A THE ALLEGED SURVEILLANCE
DURING THE 2016 CAMPAIGN.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
ANY ILLEGAL SURVEILLANCE INTO
THE CAMPAIGN OR INDIVIDUALS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CAMPAIGN BY
THE FBI OCCURRED?
>> I DON'T THINK I PERSONALLY
HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF THAT SORT.
>> AS TENSIONS BETWEEN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ESCALATE
OVER ACCESS TO THE FULL SPECIAL
REPORT AND UNDERLYING RECORDS,
THE SENIOR DEMOCRAT SHOT BACK
AFTER THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
SAID THAT THE DEMS CAN'T LET GO.
>> IT IS OVER.
>> YOU ARE SAYING IT IS A
MELTDOWN.
AN ABSOLUTE MELTDOWN.
>> MITCH McCONNELL IS AIDING
AND ABETTING IT BY REFUSING TO
DO ANYTHING.
IT MAY BE WHAT TRUMP ONCE,
WANTING THE RUSSIANS TO
PARTICIPATE IN TELLING THEM TO
DO NOTHING.
TO >> THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IS POISED TO VOTE
WEDNESDAY MORNING, BECAUSE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS NOT
INCLUDED THE ENTIRE MUELLER REPR
INCLUDED THE ENTIRE MUELLER REPT
INCLUDING GRAND JURY MATERIAL